I have to be very honest with you I
speaker of the house and watching more
closely my races for the House of
Representatives I did view with great
pride the candidacy of Senator Hillary
Clinton for president of the United
States and I think all America either
new or learned that she was ready to be
President with her great intellect agree
commitment to a better future with her
stamina to campaign and to be President
I think Hillary Clinton removed all
doubt that the American people were
ready for a woman president and that the
American people made that statement
themselves the but elections are about
choices and people made another choice
in the election I think another
excellent choice I myself was neutral in
the race being the chair of the
convention I would been happy with
either result I think we had to it came
down to two great choices although we
had several other great choices along
the way others will be reviewing this
overtime and reviewing what the press
said and did and the rest about
Hillary's Senator Clinton's candidacy
and but I have not studied it
scientifically to say anything except
that she made a great campaign and when
women are in politics there are those
with their own is event people with
their own insecurities who will resort
to sexism sometimes wittingly sometimes
unwittingly always inappropriately
you